in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Ryan
and Ani are here hey guys how are you
we're great welcome welcome where're you
from Knoxville Tennessee ah fine good
Tennessee folks that's where I'm from I
was born in Maryville just south of
there Merville properly pronounced yes
all right cool
so welcome how much dad of YouTube paid
off we paid off just shy of $22,000 cool
how long did that take exactly 24 months
good for you and range of income during
that two years we started about 70,000
and we ended up just shy of 85,000 cool
what do you guys do for a living I'm a
middle school health teacher oh God
and I'm a partner in a small landscape
design firm good for you gosh excellent
excellent so you paid off about a
thousand bucks a month give or take
mm-hmm and did you sell stuff a little
bit we had a few garage sales we sold
everything that wasn't nailed down okay
but nothing huge the 22,000 mainly cash
flowed correct okay cool cool what kind
of debt was this the debt was primarily
two automobiles and just a little bit on
the credit card that we you know we
thought we were doing well and paying it
off monthly but that was still there as
well okay cool
so something happened what happened two
years ago well it felt like we were
working just too hard to feel guilty for
every single purchase that we were
making it felt like we were always
behind always trying to catch up we
hadn't been on a family vacation ever
and we hadn't been on a vacation since
our honeymoon even before we had kids
and still every every purchase we made
there was guilt nothing was happening we
were we were just still not interesting
I hate you know I had forgotten that
feeling until you said that but I
distinctly remember standing in the
grocery store and I'm writing a check
this is back before we did the envelope
system we were broke and I'm writing a
check to buy groceries and I'm feeling
guilty
behind groceries because I don't know if
I just use the money that we need to pay
the light bill with because we were so
disorganized and so out of control and
there's
there's that lingering sense of guilt
every time you reach towards the cash
register there's no way you can enjoy a
purchase I had forgotten that that's
very insightful besides that fact you
know Ani I was on board with your show
like caught it on on the air driving
thing kind of fell in love with what you
know what you preach and is your message
and I had a I was worried about how to
get Ani on board and when she said that
she wanted to go back to grad school I
said this was my perfect opportunity
here's the CDs put him in your car
listen to him and it wasn't I think you
got through him in about a week and she
went to grad school haha we ended up
cash flowing that as well throughout
that the debt-free snobol are the debts
noble awesome okay she got your mattress
net yes yes I did good for you nice job
very good nice jump and pay in Tennessee
when that happens yes so good for you
very well done so how does it feel now
that you don't have any payments it
feels free have you ever had no payments
since you got married no no we haven't
no so I mean how long you been married I
like to come up on nine years all right
very cool you guys well done well done
I'm very proud of you so what do you
tell people when they say you paid off
$22,000 how did you do that what's the
key to getting out of debt the key is
definitely the cash and the envelopes at
the end of the month when it's gone it's
gone it was very challenging and when as
the end of the month would come up and
there were still groceries to buy you
know the last week of every month we've
really just been scraping what can we
find in the freezer what can I make out
of the rice that's in the pantry here
and there so that's that's the most
challenging part but we tell them you
know you use the cash in the envelopes
and when it's gone it's gone there's no
cheating just like that I tried to cheat
too many times and but once you got her
on the program you were you were baked
by yeah once on he's on something you
don't mess with her this is I could tell
this right here good for you guys very
very well done
well very proud of you good excellent
job well we're gonna give you a copy of
Chris Hogan's retire inspired book
that's the next chapter of your life to
go ahead and now build wealth and you
know live and give like no one else now
get that vacation line
so I bet you got that plan don't you a
little bit was so are we actually ended
up hang up off the debt just a couple
months ago and so immediately after we
did take our very first family vacation
oh good where'd you go Norfolk Virginia
that works good for you why did it go
excellent excellent
and your kiddos are with you yeah how
old are they Sammy is five and Ellie Jo
is three all right and they're going to
help with the debt free scream okay very
cool for those of you looking into your
radio you can see two kids joining them
right now very cool stuff all right
it's Ryan and Ani Sammy and Ellie Jo
from Knoxville twenty-two thousand
dollars paid off in 24 months making
seventy to eighty five thousand a year
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one we're debt-free
way to go you guys very very very well
done hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or twenty seven
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
economy